French president Emmanuel Macron has condemned
as 'inexcusable' the brutal repression of
Algerian protesters by Paris police 60 years
ago.
On October 17, 1961, officers carried out
a deadly crackdown on a demonstration by tens
of thousands of Algerians, in one of the darkest
episodes in post war France.
Some historians say more than 200 people were
killed in the violence.
It's the first time a French president has
attended a memorial ceremony for the Algerians
killed on that night.
Emmanuel Macron joined relatives of the victims
in paying tribute.
60 years ago at this spot, bodies were fished
out from the Seine river.
An estimated 25 thousand Algerians rallied
peacefully in protest against a curfew imposed
on them alone.
Police responded without mercy, arresting
nearly 12-thousand and killing dozens, throwing
their bodies into the river.
Many others were taken away to sorting centers
and then deported.
Said Abtout was there that night.
"The police came.
When we they got to us, they started to massacre
people, hitting them with batons on the head,
then kicking them in head with their shoes
on.
I'd never seen anything like that."
The violence occurred in the final year of
France's violent attempt to keep Algeria as
one of its colonies.
For decades, successive administrations ignored
the massacre.
President Macron's condemnation of the killings
was only issued in a written statement and
did not include an apology.
This year's commemoration took place amid
diplomatic tensions between both countries
over their history.